[Music]
hi both of us address on psychology it's
been a while so tonight I wanted to show
you a game that I played a while ago
against the Grandmaster about 200 rating
points more than me I had black and I
tried to use what I say and I try to
apply it in the game and I was pretty
happy with how the game turned out so
let's dive in so I remember that I did
have the chance to look at what he plays
before the game so just for a little bit
I checked to see what to expect and I
saw that he really likes to get into
these position like he's this is this
was the highest possibility of what
would happen was either if it starts
with d4 or start with Knight f3 so it
could have started either ways cuz these
would have been my move order regardless
and then we would have reached the same
position so yeah I had a chance to look
at what he played and I realized that
regardless of what he plays this is
probably going to happen and this is a
position that I feel very comfortable in
it just it's really it's quite solid and
do you have a good strategic plan and it
could easily change to a dynamic
position so I really like that and this
move a4 was quite unusual in my eyes
because they use
moves are something with either c4 which
is the main line and the idea is that
either the knight wants to come out from
c3 or there are some different tactical
dynamic and tactical ideas to try and
exploit this diagonal and then this week
Square and I I've actually never seen
this move a4 before before this game and
after a four I just realized that I want
to play normal chess and I don't see any
immediate threat so I wasn't going to
address it probably if I was thinking
about it right now I would have given a
five more serious consideration
just because if a five kind of blocks
any idea over here and in a long run I
might have some ideas with bringing the
Knights from the corner if I don't want
to touch my D and C pawn and just to
have some control just brainstorming on
ideas and so probably I would have given
move a five more consideration but
anyways I decided to just go with what I
know and I casted and he pushed a little
bit with a five which I don't really
understand and I I think I forgot to
mention but sure the name of this
opening is
it really depends on what why--it's does
because sometimes there is g3 sometimes
they played with III but there's the
start of it the first move good night f3
they usually call it pretty but it
really depends on how the game
progresses because right now it's not a
very typical writing anymore
and this is something more like Queen
Indian style anyways so I decided to not
take this because it seemed like if I
take it then I'm putting more meaning
into this whole a5 a4 a5 idea and if I
don't address it at all then it could
beat the den whoops let's say I just
develop or try to do something then it's
good also this a5 a4 a5 would mean
something and I just didn't want it to
mean anything for white so I decided to
play b5 to to somehow take more space
and now there is not going to be c4
anymore and this pawn is a little weak I
could start having ideas on this pawn
because before isn't going to happen as
white anymore at least right now and so
how about we take a moment and think
about this position like what white
wants what black wants in a little wrong
long run especially because this is a
very positional game so let's take a
second and think about that
sure
so do we have any ideas I'm gonna try
and look at the chat as much as I can
but it might be a little hard
okay we have some ideas
okay so we how about the audience anyone
anything so I was black you just want to
push the pawns okay it does make sense
and ideally I agree ideally it would be
nice to do that but what about white
what do you think white should do
okay so you basically wanna try and push
in the queenside with white and in the
center with black all right yeah I think
that's a nice idea so in the game
actually he played queen d3 and I think
his idea was pretty simple he just
wanted to keep looking towards the
Dakota Queen side and at the same time
have an idea maybe if the knight can get
out in time to try and push
efore or c4 and so I think the move for
black should be very very easy but so
let me know what you think black should
do right now
so you just want to keep your pawn
basically yeah yeah I agree because
there are you could definitely think
about pushing the pawn a little bit
farther but the problem I think is that
if c4 now then what do you want to do do
you want to just keep the palms over
here
are you gonna play c5 or are you going
to take this pawn because if you take it
I think this Knights can take and this
is a okay for white and white is
developing very logically there as after
c5 for probably it looks good for it
looks playable for both side so I don't
think there is anything to be worried
about seriously right now but anyways I
I went with a six as well because I just
wanted to keep defending my pawn and now
this idea of it c4 was played now what
do you think
well black should do should black takes
with black push
so you just want to bring your pieces on
simply but do you think 96 works right
now I'm asking this because if excuse me
yeah because I think if 96 right now
what if C takes B 5 yeah but I do like
the idea that you're trying to develop
your pieces
sorry
so okay we have some suggestions with
before I think on chat we have some
suggestion with Bishop before but my I
have some internet connection problems
right now it's kind of hard to read to
see yeah I'm trying to look at it on the
phone and I can't really connect to
Wi-Fi yeah so okay anyways we have some
ideas with before and I did manage to
see a bishop efore and yeah okay we have
few Bishop e-force okay we're going with
this ship efore yeah so I think before
it is nice but I think the problem with
before is that your pawn is kind of a
little isolated than alone over here so
if by any chance white could try and
push something maybe play some efore and
maybe trying to play C 5 then this pawn
is really weak does it make sense okay
so after Bishop b4 what do you think
what should do what where should white
try to place the Queen
okay yeah I left ID with Queen b3 do you
see any other logical useful places for
the Queen
do we have anything on the chat
here's a typically a 25 second delay
okay
anything
because I already have a queen bee three
live here current so yeah I agree Queen
B 3 is the best one because I think the
problem is that if you were to play
something like if you were to move your
queen somewhere that you're not supposed
to this pawn falls and then d5 can come
after pretty immediately and the other
problem is that if you want to c3
now the idea with before could be more
useful because now even if you play
Queen b3 I can think about pushing to c5
or even immediately try and play maybe
maybe knight c6 and now I have some
ideas of rook b8 protecting upon I have
enough time P to develop the things I
wanted so that's why Queen b3 should be
the main move and now black has to -
ideally two moves to seriously consider
I mean I'm sure there are other
candidates but the these two make the
most sense so maybe give it a try
because these are like this is not
really open this is not really known
opening anymore after a four and it's
just something that you're trying to
figure out in the game and so they're
not you just have to go move by move and
try to follow the plan instead of
knowing what you're doing beforehand
that's why I'm trying to ask every move
what do you want to do and what are you
trying to develop so yeah
what's up what do you want to develop
okay I like the idea nice c6 what I'll
see you guys
oops sorry this right now there are two
moves that you should consider and
before isn't really one of them let me
delete that there we go sorry you didn't
say the wrong move I just clicked on the
wrong thing
yeah so yeah you all use that both of
the candidates moves that you should
think about so a derby should I think
Pete xe4 is good 96 is also good I do
believe that 96 is slightly better just
because you are developing faster and
taking this doesn't really work because
first thing that comes in mind is what
if take take what do you think you
should do now
you're attacking with Utes defended by
two home I think you have something much
more straightforward
I like it but I think the move that I'm
considering is still more
straightforward he just took your pawn
so you're a pawn down right do you see
any direct move to try and take the pawn
back any pawn
yeah I think this is the simplest one
that at least deserves to be considered
first before any other have to takes
because if you take with the pawn well I
just take and the center is amazing
right and there's so many ideas and just
you're gonna try and keep this night
over here
and keep pushing even if you can if you
take with the bishop after I take your
pawn I think Queen d3 is the only move I
think because if you go away I can take
consider taking your your Bishop more
seriously and after Queen d3 now I think
I have to take it because the rook is
under attack the knight is under attack
I'm sure someone would think about
sacrifice and its might work and at some
point but I think this is the only
realistic thing and then you would just
push for the center and try to trick
your opponent into getting that a five
pawn and yeah if you have to go it's
okay it will be on youtube later
yeah go go play your tournaments and it
will be on YouTube good luck sure yeah
so that's what we were thinking about as
between knight c6 or B take c4 and so I
still think 96 96 is more my style right
now rather than be take c4 and so
ideally I would want to be able to
develop instead of trying to eat pawns
but I think be take c4 is also it's good
enough for
for this situation and after B takes it
for well clean has to take so now I have
to figure out how to develop my pieces
and I'm gonna give the online audience a
minute or two to think about that
because apparently my Wi-Fi has
connected so yay
Wow we have 91 viewers haha let's get it
to 100 please thank you yeah so anyways
we I'm still looking for well
suggestions from a line audience but the
tip that I can give is you're almost
under developing but don't leave your
pieces hanging so think what piece is
hanging and try to make that stronger
oh I got a I got a suggestion yay d5 um
I like t5 but I feel like when you play
d5 your Bishop is really committed to
that square and then later on if you
play let's say you play d5 the queen
would let's say go to B 3 or C 3 or yeah
and I think the issue is that then this
night could come and try to attack your
Bishop and you don't necessarily know if
that's what you want to commit to right
now and the other thing is this Bishop
now now has a purpose will go to f4 and
start going after this pawn even though
it might not work immediately but it's
just pressure and it's better to try
avoiding having that pressure so well I
put Bishop d5 just because this Bishop
was kind of hanging over there and I
wanted it to be safer and now if Queen /
pretty much regardless of where the
Queen goes assuming it's not a blunder I
would want to play knight c6 so for
example if Queen goes to a 4 knight c6
if the Queen would go to c2 again knight
c6 just because this night belongs to c6
and I don't necessarily know where
exactly I would want my pawns my c7 and
these seven pounds to be because I don't
know if I want to push them just yet and
that's why I would put the knives where
I know I want the night to me and okay
so what do you think White's could do
because why still has to finish
developing
so I gonna suggest in about 9c3 detering
Knight c3 works and think about why I
played knight c6 it it's to develop but
it's not the only idea
okay think about this if right now that
was blacks to move what would you do
we have a small message yellow message
over here
so I'm getting a lot of interesting
ideas about 90 P fours but I think there
I what I want to do is kind of way
simpler than that
I see something defenseless and I'm
going after it
pretty much
hmm I'm still getting a lot of work PA
tonight before those are good idea but I
love eating pants think about pants yes
thank you finally someone lots of lols
Bishop takes f3 yeah I mean that that
was pretty much my idea if you're not
gonna defend your pawn or if we were not
I'm going to eat that pawn and probably
say thank you in my mind so if you play
whoops if you were to play Knight c3 I
would definitely take this and I would
just enjoy my life with one pawn more
and then I would just dominate the
center and this should be pretty easy
after that so all right after so as soon
as I play knight c6 if you're thinking
about white if you're white and you're
thinking what you should do is white you
should immediately know that's 96 I want
to go I'm going after your d4 pawn so
the negative next one that you do should
have something to do with defending
dad's area either the d4 pawn or some
support for f3 so I played after 96 he
played 92 and I'm assuming his idea was
very simple to just defend this guy and
now I can't do that anymore cuz of well
now it's defended and it's kind of
pointless to give my strong bishop up so
after Knight teach you I realized that
my knight here this is this job is done
and it needs to relocate so that's why I
played night before also the idea with
night before was that I simply want to
try and push some pawns over here to get
more space to try and get my pawns in
center and also if it was wise to move
again right now why it has this efore
idea right so if I did something
weird like roof p8e for would kind of
hurt my bishop a little bit so that's
why night before opening up a room for
Bishop opening up room for my C pawn to
go and so after Queen b1 I decided to
play c5 mainly because well if you take
awesome now I can now this makes so much
sense my bishop is so strong over here
and both my bishops have these two
diagonals and it just looks very
comfortable for black and very
uncomfortable for whites so I'm assuming
that's why he played
eform he was also a grandmaster like 25
70 so I'm sure he saw these while I was
thinking about them as well
anyways so after 84
I played Bishop c6 mainly because well I
don't want to play Bishop e7 because
it's I don't know if I want my rook to
come to b8 at some point
anyways Bishop c6 I was a little
surprised after E 5 because mmm well
first of all what else can but White's
do but objectively when you play e5 now
I'm going to play this 95 and this just
feels very comfortable just having this
strong Knights over here in this
outposts and
yeah it felt really nice to be honest
and so after 94 another thing that you
could notice is that right now my game
is more to our centre towards Queen side
while white is going from center more
towards Queens sorry King side a lot of
sides right now and so the thing is it's
mainly determined because of the pawn
structure so just because of these pawns
over here my king is a little bit
undefended and it gives white some ideas
to try and use that while because of the
pawn structure because I have this pawn
over here and I have more space over
here and I have these outposts or in the
Queen side it's yeah so I just saw
comments from mr. spongebob or lots of
lols or I'm running out of names funny
names yeah so black has kind of
equalized not only equalized but black
is at least slightly better and yeah so
he my opponent after Knight e4 well he
played 94 with the idea to do Knight g5
at some point and I decided to ignore
this and I took on d4 because I kind of
thought that's taking on d4 I thought it
was time to open up the center a little
but after the game I realized that
Bishop e5 would have also been a viable
option at least it was something that I
considered very briefly but I didn't
know if I wanted to play it in the game
necessarily because
rook t1 Bishop e2 and I'm kind of
pushing this night to go to g5
and I wasn't sure if this is how I want
to go well I mean if you take well this
false but when you take goodnight and I
did I do believe that I see I saw this
position up until here
and I kind of stopped thinking about it
which was a mistake because right now I
have this move see for which is pretty
strong and it's going for more outposts
and I think I should have done this and
I kind of regretted it because it would
have made so much sense
but anyways so I decided to simplify the
game a little bit and I decided to go
for a prophylactic moves such as h6
other moves to consider work like rook
b8
or Queen c7 but I simply just wanted to
do the prophylaxis move and not worry
about ninety five ever again yeah
and he played Bishop d2 and maybe take a
minute to think about this position
because a lot of things have changed
since the last time I asked so yeah
think what would you want to do with
black any ideas any threats
mmm 98 viewers two more please
I mean one of them is ah and I missed it
okay
well I see a Bishop b5 I see rook b8 I
see things like that but I think I think
the the thing to consider is well after
Bishop b5 first of all is why it's gonna
take this and also aren't you worried
about you know some takings and if you
take with the knight then maybe some
ideas and mmm alright Bishop sorry if
Bishop b5 sorry I completely forgot you
should take this first and then you
could try and have some ideas with you
know trying to put more pressure on this
night because it spins and I just don't
know if I was comfortable with that
especially because the bishop on c6 is
doing well I don't think I need to move
it because if you take it I can just
take back with the knight list of all
and keep attacking you're a five pawn
and yeah
[Music]
okay so I like the idea root b8 just
because it was a very simple move and
now I want to do the idea with Bishop b5
so let's say Lu you play something
simple like rook e1 I want to play
Bishop e5 and now when you take it
instead of having to take with the pawn
I can just take with the rook and I'm
going after this pawn and I really like
that idea and I don't really have to to
think about this diagonal and this pin
anymore because my rook is up here
already so yeah and so he just this is
how the game actually was played and yes
101 and I see it this time yeah so take
a second take 30 seconds and think about
whether or not white should try to
exchange some pieces off or if not then
what do you want to do it right because
I'm going after that a5 Khan
for your ears
no I don't have coronavirus I just go to
help center yesterday but thank you for
thank you for the asking
nope they'd shake me last yesterday
yeah all the black pieces are on Quinn
son it's pretty true except for the
answer okay so I want to get through
with the game so I kind of have to rush
a little sorry and so at this point he
decided to go with Knight c3 just to try
and open up a little bit mainly because
I know it's kind of cliche that you
heard that two bishops like open center
but it's also true two bishops do like
open center because if the center is
closed and all the pieces are kind of
like like this clutter together then you
can't really use the two pieces the two
bishops so and that's only compensation
that wise could consider right now and
so this is actually how the game went
down and I managed to get upon and I
decided to try and free up my f8 rook
because right now if I did if I play
something like Queen c7 more likely than
not he's going to take back his pawn and
now he has a slightly a more active
position because this pawn is kind of I
can't really push it I mean I can but I
need more preparation like I need to try
and play route d8 and then I need to try
and push and I don't know if it's going
to actually work technically I could try
to take take maybe take on b2 maybe at
least it doesn't look that appealing to
me just because there could always be
more pressure on my on my Kings side
even though I have one more pawn there
could just this isn't the ideal position
that I would want just looking at it
from here I would much rather place my
queen on c8 s have it's happy and
protecting my palms rather than get to
that position where White has a lot of
game oh yeah it's not a good advice
don't let your opponent get too much
game yeah so yeah at this point queen 8
4 was played and I realized that okay
this night has got to come back a little
but my position started to gets really
passive and I kind of wonder me if it
was words worth it going after this pawn
I think I don't know if I would do it
again but at this point I'm very
committed to taking upon and I don't
really know what else to do because my
two bishops are gone and I think the
points where I couldn't I could have
avoided it was Bishop b5 and it would
have still kept the pressure in center
and I was more comfortable with that the
other than having this more pawn but
being slightly uncomfortable because now
I have to try and keep the pawn because
if I just give up the pawn that I have
more than why it has two bishops and
probably a passed pawn that's going to
be defended the dispatch of this bishop
another rook and it would have been very
uncomfortable so I tried to keep my pawn
as hard as I could and at this point
there it's kind of realistically this
pawn would fall but at the same time if
this pawn falls it's kind of okay
because we would exchange he would give
up his two bishops for this pawn and I
was ok with that as long as he didn't
have the two bishops I could still have
a good enough game so I decided to try
and open up the game a little bit and I
think my idea was that well if you take
I am simply going to take back and try
to go for this
this pond over here and maybe at some
point d5 and well since he was a
grandmaster he didn't give me that
option and he simply played Bishop d3
now Bishop d3 there could be some ideas
with Queen e4 and looking at some
uncomfortable mates over here so I
decided to try and exchange Queens
because I simply didn't really I
realized that there isn't anything left
in the board with Queens on it for me to
fight for because I can't really I don't
really have any plans with the Queens on
the board he's the one who's pushing so
I just didn't like having that sort of
pressure so I went to offering to
exchange Queens and if he refused well
work any places Queen if he just goes
somewhere else I could probably just
play f5 and all of his hopes of attacks
on the Kings side would just be over so
I think that's why he just decided to
agree to the Queen exchange and then a
little more exchange and well he kind of
can't take the pawn over here and go to
a rook ends game which is most likely
going to end in a draw well
theoretically but he decided to push a
little bit more for them just to bring
the king a little bit closer before
going through that's true Ken's game and
I realized that I can't really bring my
king any closer and it's now or never I
have to push this pawn or I'm not going
to actually have any game and he would
have more he would have the upper hand
basically even though I'm still one pawn
more in the game the last thing that I
thought about was maybe ninety six would
have worked because if you take it with
the rook I could think about night
before
could also think about rugby aids and I
could try and start putting pressure on
this pawn now if you play you're okay -
I have 94 if you don't fly you're okay -
well your pawn is kind of falling so
probably I could have considered knight
c6 more seriously and so I decided to go
with d5 and I'm going to keep I'm going
to rush it a little because I still have
to get through the endgame and I have
about five minutes so yay my opponent
decided to ignore the fact that I still
have one pawn more and keep going for
the space advantage and pieces
activities and I if it was why to move
again white would give me this check and
my King would have to go back to g8 and
I was just that was not going to happen
in that game I know my king is not going
back so I just played f5 and so my idea
was if you give me the check rook p7 I'm
going to simply play King f6 or g6
either one so he simply went for rook b6
and started to push a little bit before
taking the pawn the a6 pawn and I
realized that okay so my my Rose job
here is over I'm gonna bring the
recloser
I'm gonna bring the King closer and as
soon as you give me this check and you
go after that pawn
ooh okay this is the last move that I'm
gonna ask you to think about because
it's kind of a cute move
thank you all checks
well I hate to spoil the fun but so I
pushed d4 check the my idea was when you
take it I'm gonna give you this check
and depends on where you go if you go to
e3 I'll simply take then if you go to e3
I'll simply take this and I'll start
pushing this yay but what if you go King
c3 now your king is against my rook and
I can give you and I can bring my knight
a little closer to the other part of the
game and this is how it actually happens
I managed to exchange the pawns off of
the board in the Queen side so now the
game is fully concentrated on the center
and King side and it's good because when
you have a knight you want the game to
be once in one side instead of all over
the boards because the bishop can get to
all over the board faster mr. Peter was
also a very good move because I had
ideas with Knight f3 check to take the
pawn or Knight g4 and attack two pawns
and Bishop e2 kind of eliminated those I
started to push a little bit more to try
and see how much activity I can get out
of this game and so up until here most
of it is very straightforward but this
Knight e5 is very interesting to me
because right now White has the option
of trying to probably move the King and
I think what I was going for was a
repetition
I think that's what I was going for well
you have to come to e3 because if you go
to e1 I have this night nasty 93 but if
you come to e3 I still have the same
checks and mmm I liked my position quite
a lot so I think that's why he realized
there isn't much to fight for anymore
and he decided to let me exchange more
pawns and now it was just very simple I
the only think I have to do is to
realize that there isn't much to push
for don't push and make blunders and to
be happy with my position basically so
at this point I really wish I could ask
you what you what you want to do I can't
you can't pause the video and think
about it before me giving it up but you
could play rook e5 simply your idea is
to cut out this king you don't want that
the King gets closer to the king side
and you want to bring your own king and
at this point I think he also realized
that this game is about to be wrapped up
with a draw and he was ok with it I just
went for the pawn and voila
yeah I really like this game especially
because I remembered this was one of the
first tournaments that I played after I
didn't play it just for a few months
when I was studying for SATs and I
really liked that that I was it going by
how I'm playing good I still got it
I still remember how to play chess and I
really like this game and now I'm gonna
sign off give the mic to our in a little
bit
and I hope you enjoyed it
you
[Music]
you